juli beginnt escort service und top ten
wir müssen über pornos reden denn mit
diesem video fordert eine petition die
abschaltung von porn habe einer der
größten porno plattform der welt die
vorwürfe die die us-amerikanische ngo
exodus kröhnert macht sind dass das
unternehmen von kindesmissbrauch und von
sexueller ausbeutung profitiert und das
ganze sogar fördert in dem video das sie
zeigen erheben sie krasse vorwürfe und
das macht erstmal sprachlos
die petition die leider gestartet hat
hat laut trafficking hab dort kommt
schon über zwei millionen unterschreibe
und die fordern jetzt alle das ende von
connor ich habe mich jetzt schon gefragt
kann es wirklich sein dass eine
öffentlich zugängliche seite voll ist
mit illegalen inhalten bis hin zu
kinderpornografie ohne dass wirklich
viel darüber gesprochen und laut darüber
diskutiert wird wie groß ist das problem
eigentlich wirklich wer kann mir
überhaupt was dazu sagen und wer sind
eigentlich die menschen hinter dieser
petition
ja und dann habe ich ganz schnell
festgestellt dass es gar nicht so
einfach ist ich habe versucht bei
behörden nachzufragen wie groß das
problem ist da wussten die leute noch
nicht mal was born hat ist zum teil
ich habe versucht mehr über das
unternehmen dahinter rauszufinden meint
geht das ist aber super intransparent
und die ngo hinter der kampagne ist
höchst umstritten
mir wäre es sehr wichtig dass die
menschen sich darüber bewusst sind dass
sie wenn sie diese petition
unterschreiben damit eine christlich
fundamentalistische gruppe unterstützen
tja was das alles bedeutet und was ich
herausfinden konnte könnt ihr euch jetzt
angucken und eins ist vorab ganz klar
wir müssen ganz dringend über das porno
business reden
eine sache ist mir vorweg super wichtig
es geht hier auf gar keinen fall darum
einen einzelnen fall oder sogar die
vorwürfe herunter zu spielen oder
kleiner zu machen sondern es geht
einfach darum zu gucken wer dahinter
steckt und wie groß das problem denn
wirklich ist aber es ist ganz klar jeder
einzelne fall von sexueller gewalt ist
schlimm und für die betroffenen super
traumatisierend und wenn das ganze dann
noch im internet zu finden ist ist es
noch eine ganze ecke schlimmer fangen
wir es einfach mal an mit ein paar
fakten zu tun habe 2009/10 allein hatte
born hab 42 milliarden besucher das sind
115 millionen besucher pro tag
die plattform ist eine der
meistbesuchten websites der welt und
gehört zu dem unternehmen meint creek
mine gag wird eine monopolstellung
nachgesagt wenn es um online pornografie
geht das unternehmen besitzt mehrere
plattformen darunter zb auch youtube und
youporn und mehrere studios die pornos
produzieren genauso wie zahlreiche
tochterunternehmen auf unterschiedlichen
kontinenten das ganze ist super
verschachtelt und öffentlich kaum
nachvollziehbar dass porno wird so
bekannt ist und es wahrscheinlich jeder
von euch kennt liegt unter anderem auch
daran dass sie eine super
marketingabteilung haben
ich weiß es nicht wahrscheinlich
erinnert ihr euch alle daran am anfang
zu hohner der locker und in italien
relativ kurze zeit später die große
nachricht die italiener bekommen
kostenlose premium bei bornheim die
plattform ihr das aber nicht erst seit
dieser petition kritisiert sondern
diverse menschen kritisieren die
plattform aus unterschiedlichen gründen
poller studios und sexarbeiter innen
sagen zum beispiel dass der regelmäßig
gegen urheberrecht verstoßen wird
jugendschützer versuchen gerade ist
sogar für deutschland eine netzsperre
das wäre das erste mal zu dich wirken
weil kaum auf jugendschutz geachtet wird
und tatsächlich ist es so jeder mensch
der internet hat und gerät dazu kann
ohne irgendeine form der überprüfung
sofort pornos auf pornos anschauen
jeder der eine e mail adresse hat kann
sich einfach einen account zulegen ich
habe selber ausprobiert innerhalb von
wenigen klicks ohne irgendwelche angaben
zu meiner person zu machen hatte ich
einen account und musste zum upload nur
ein
bestätigen dass ich über 18 bin und dass
ich die rechte an dem material
innerhalb von wenigen minuten war mein
video an bleiben diverse formate und
medien berichten immer wieder von
revenge bord von heimlich gefilmten
aufnahmen und dann von den problemen dem
auch wieder herr zu werden und die
aufnahme wieder löschen zu lassen
das ist also insgesamt nicht neu dass es
unternehmen umstritten ist aber die
vorwürfe und forderungen von extrem
square haben die neue qualität
sie fordern die abschaltung und sie
fordern dass die sie aus zur
verantwortung gezogen werden ich habe
jetzt die möglichkeit mit leider michael
bay zu sprechen sie ist die initiatorin
der petition die mittlerweile zwei
millionen menschen unterschrieben haben
und ich bin gespannt was als beweis für
diese krassen vorwürfe zitiert access
client erster linie medienberichte
außerdem sprechen sie von menschen die
auf social media kanälen sich dazu
äußern und vermutlichen opfern die sich
direkt am trafic abwenden es gibt
tatsächlich einige seriöse
medienberichte in denen zum teil
minderjährige frauen davon berichten
dass sie gegen ihren willen auf porno ab
gelandet sind und dann auch große
probleme hatten das wieder zu löschen
in einem fall wurden die betreiber von
der seite girls dupont zu einer
millionenstrafe verurteilt und das unter
anderem auch deshalb weil sie ihre
videos auch auf porno veröffentlicht
haben also im internet frei zugänglich
ohne dass die personen die dabei gedreht
wurden überhaupt davon osten in dem
gerichtsurteil ist tatsächlich auch von
connect die rede einfach als plattform
auf den videos vertrieben wurden
außerdem soll es nach dem urteil echt
einige zeit gedauert haben bis borna die
videos dann tatsächlich gelöscht hat
genaue zahlen
wie viele mutmaßliche opfer sich bei
leider gemeldet haben sie aus
berichterstattung kennt oder sie als
grundlage der ganzen petition zählt
konnte sie mir nicht nennen obwohl ich
mehrfach danach gefragt
im interview hat mir leider kaum harte
beweise dafür vorgelegt deswegen habe
ich sie schriftlich noch einmal danach
gefragt ja sie hat mir dann eine
präsentation geschickt in der sie
weitere medienberichte screenshots von
videos titeln und kommentaren auf born
hab gesammelt hat und genauso auch
nachrichten die haben sie selbst
geschickt wurden einige zeigen ganz klar
fragwürdige inhalte aber nichts davon
ist von offizieller seite oder von
behörden bestätigt ihre präsentation
unterstützt also ihre vorwürfe ich kann
das allerdings nicht final überprüfen
weil es wie gesagt screenshots sind und
links die natürlich nicht mehr
funktionieren deswegen war es natürlich
super wichtig pop selbst wort kommen zu
lassen und ich habe sie schriftlich mit
den vorwürfen konfrontiert entspreche
hat dann ziemlich schnell alle vorwürfe
entschieden zurückgewiesen er schreibt
horn hat setzt sich beharrlich dafür ein
illegale inhalte aus dem internet
auszurotten und zu bekämpfen das gilt
auch für nicht einvernehmliche und
minderjährige inhalte jegliche
unterstellung dass das anders sein
sollte es kategorisch und faktisch
falsch der sprecher hat mir dann auch
geschrieben wie kork sicherstellen will
dass keine illegalen inhalte auf der
plattform sind und das passiert unter
anderem mit diversen k s mit fingerprint
software also ganz viele technische
dinge im hintergrund aber auch dass hier
das beinhaltet die anstellung eines
großen teams an menschliche moderatoren
die händisch jeden einzelnen ab laut
überprüfen jeden einzeln ab laut ich
habe das hier noch mal aufgeschrieben im
polder report 2009 10 steht dass jedes
jahr 638 millionen videos hochgeladen
werden
das sind über 170 jahre an content im
jahr also 2,8 stunden material pro
minute ich frage mich was für ein team
da wirklich jedes einzelne ding
kontrollieren soll
und als ich dann braun hat nachgefragt
habe nach details wie viele menschen das
überhaupt sicherstellen sollen
wie viele menschen in den team arbeiten
wie groß das ist wie viel prozent des
videos die sich anschauen
darauf habe ich keine antwort bekommen
warum weil das die arbeit von
kriminellen erleichtern würde
außerdem wer das ganze hier bei
plattformen wie twitter und facebook
wesentlich schlimmer und das ist
tatsächlich so wenn es um
kinderpornographie geht nennen twitter
und facebook sehr sehr hohe zahlen
das ist aber gar nicht möglich das mit
pomp zu vergleichen dienen nämlich gar
keine zahlen es gibt eine stelle in den
usa das netzwerk des national center for
exploited children bei dem alle dort
ansässigen provider ihre verdachtsfälle
melden müssen
und in der statistik hatte facebook
2009/10 15,9 millionen verdächtige
inhalte gemeldet google 450.000 82.000
twitter 45 1700 sogar airbnb meldet 59
fälle der porno gigant meint gibt hat
laut statistik in diesem fall keinen
einzigen fall
jetzt sagt kolrep das könnte daran
liegen dass er nur amerikanische firmen
erfasst sind hackmack antwortet mir
nicht und porn ablegt seine eigenen
zahlen nicht offen
sie fahren mich nur darauf verwiesen
dass die britische beschwerdestelle in
den jahren von 2017 bis 2019 118 fälle
von kindesmissbrauch auf poller gefunden
hat trotzdem bleibt ist natürlich die
frage wie groß ist das problem von
pollack kommen wir nicht wirklich an
zahlen und das center antwortet nicht
deswegen wollte ich gerade auch für
deutschland einfach mal wissen wie ist
die lage hier vor ort das bka erhebt
keine statistik dazu von welcher
plattform die illegalen inhalte kommen
das heißt sie können sich einschätzen
sagen aber sie konnten keine
signifikante problematik in bezug auf
das internetportal horner fest
denn die zentralstelle für
internetkriminalität der
generalstaatsanwaltschaft in frankfurt
hat mir geschrieben dass plattform wie
porno ab und youporn bisher keine rolle
in den ermittlungen gespielt haben
ob das jetzt alles bedeutet dass das
ganze halb so wild ist und kein großes
problem das kann man nicht abschließend
beurteilen denn die behörden scheint es
nicht so möglich auch maschinen zu haben
es gibt kaum bundesweite statistiken und
wenn man sich das ganze einfach mal
anschaut dann gibt es in deutschland
noch nicht wirklich ein problem bewusst
sein was diese ganzen themenkomplex
angeht und viele menschen wissen auch
einfach nicht darüber bescheid es gibt
kaum öffentliche diskussionen aber man
muss dabei wohl von einer relativ großen
dunkelziffer ausgehen das heißt man kann
gar nicht abschließend sagen wie groß
das problem tatsächlich ist dann oft
wissen opfer ja gar nicht dass sie im
internet zu finden sind oder sie schäme
sich dann das ganze anzuzeigen
man hat manchmal so ein bisschen das
gefühl es geht um zwei fronten und es
geht darum wer recht hat aber eigentlich
geht es ja um ein ganz anderes problem
nämlich darum dass sexuelle gewalt und
solche sachen im internet zu finden sind
und das ist jetzt eine bestimmte
plattform zu last gelegt wird weil das
ganze suppe unwichtig ist war es mir
wichtig mit jemandem zu sprechen der
sich damit auskennt und ich konnte mit
madita bewegen sprechen sie ist
kulturwissenschaftlerin und
amerikanistik und forscht seit jahren
zur pornografie ich stehe dieser
petition durchaus kritisch gegenüber
nicht unbedingt aufgrund dessen was sie
fordert sondern eher auf grund dessen
wer dahintersteht
viele experten kritisieren excel es sei
denn die audi hinter der petition steht
mir wäre es sehr wichtig dass die
menschen sich darüber bewusst sind dass
sie wenn sie diese petition
unterschreiben damit eine christlich
fundamentalistische gruppe unterstützen
und menschen den rücken stärken die sich
eigentlich eben nicht für die rechte von
frauen und anderen gruppen einsetzen
sondern tatsächlich auch öffentlich sich
gegen ein recht auf abtreibung gegen
rechte trierer menschen und letzten
endes auch gegen rechte von
sexarbeiterinnen aussprechen was ist
etwas was ich nicht mit meinem namen
unterstützen möchte
da ich mit meiner unmittelbaren sprechen
konnte habe ich sie auch zu den
vorwürfen befragt
auf der seite wird explizit betont die
petition sei nicht religiös für die
petition an sich stimmt das auch die ngo
dahinter ist es aber auf jeden fall als
ich leider mikrowelt konkret mit der
einschätzung von man die themen
konfrontiert habe hat sie mich auf ein
statement hingewiesen was auf der seite
von extremisten veröffentlicht wurde
wo sie sich davon sehr stark
distanzieren und konrad wiederum
vorwerfen einer kampagne zu fahren und
die ngo im schlechten licht dastehen
lassen zu wollen
man beobachtet excel das kreuz aber
schon länger und sie bleibt bei ihrer
einschätzung ich selbst habe die
petition nicht unterschrieben
aus genau diesen gründen das bedeutet
für mich aber nicht dass ich borna
verteidigen möchte oder dass ich mich
auf die seite von paul hug stelle in
dieser diskussion und ob man jetzt so
eine petition unterstützen will das muss
am ende jeder für sich selbst
entscheiden
bonn hat ist absolut ein fragwürdiges
unternehmen beziehungsweise meint die
großunternehmen dahinter steht ist es
wichtig dass wir darüber sprechen ich
finde es wichtig dass wir nicht
pornografie und die industrie die
dahintersteht ausklammern aus unserer
öffentlichen unterhaltung ich finde es
wichtig dass kritisch zu hinterfragen
ich habe eben nur angst dass es in die
falschen bahn geleitet wird selbst wenn
diese petition jetzt dazu führen sollte
korn habe zu zerschlagen oder zu
verbieten würde das dann was verändern
ich denke man kann sagen diese petition
ist eigentlich eine vermeintlich
einfache lösungen für sehr viel
komplexere probleme so ähnlich sieht es
auch der bundesverband für
frauenberatungsstellen und frauennotrufe
die beraten opfer von sexueller gewalt
auch im internet
und auch sie halten wenig von der
petition und eine abschaltung von born
habe das abschalten einer bestimmten
plattform wird jedoch kaum regulierende
wirkung haben da ist überall im netz
solche videos und plattformen gibt zudem
werden diskussionen und verbote solcher
plattform meiner wahrnehmung nach häufig
genutzt und pornografische inhalte und
deren konsum perse mit sexualisierter
gewalt gleichzusetzen denn nur weil die
plattform weg ist ist das problem
natürlich nicht gelöst trotzdem könnte
und müsste porn habt mehr tun und das
ganze gilt angefangen vom jugendschutz
darüber zu überprüfen werde welches
material hochlädt bis zur
moderationsprozess und dass das
unternehmen so intransparent ist und
auch mit zahlen so intransparent um geld
macht das ganze nicht einfacher im
grunde fehlt unserer over sechsten und
an der fakten gesellschaft 1 aufklärung
und sexuelle bildung im kern dieses
ganzen problems steht eigentlich das wie
pornografie dermaßen stigmatisiert haben
dass niemand mehr hinguckt also dass
dort einfach so eine grauzone auch eine
juristische grauzone
entstanden ist so viele menschen das
gefühl haben sie können einfach machen
was sie möchten
ein problem das wir auch im digitalen
raum tendenziell beobachten durch das
internet wurde porno zum mainstream und
das eigentlich immer und überall für
jeden verfügbar und das reicht von ganz
normalen film über fragwürdige inhalte
bis hin zu höchst abscheulichen und
illegalen inhalten und dem ganzen sind
kinder und jugendliche genauso
ausgesetzt mehr wachsen und dafür muss
man noch nicht mal ein startet das
gibt's auf dem porno plattform auf
social media kanälen oder sogar whatsapp
gruppen und darüber gesprochen wird aber
absolut gar nicht die wichtigeren fragen
die wir uns denke ich stellen müssen
sind die nach nach toxischer
männlichkeit nach konstanz als etwas was
wir lernen müssen nach sexueller bildung
für junge menschen damit sie ermächtigt
sind sich zu schützen und eine gesunde
sexualität so haben über
verantwortungsbewussten umgang über
unsere aufgabe als konsumentinnen von
medien war auch medienkompetenz
das sind am ende denke ich die fragen
die wir uns stellen müssen und auch die
wurzeln des ganzen an denen ich
persönlich eher ansetzen würde
bei einer recherche gezeigt dass fehlt
an allen ecken und enden an einer
unterhaltung über pornographie und über
pornografie im internet und darüber wie
wir als gesellschaft damit umgehen
wollen das problem hat ganz ganz viele
ebenen und facetten und dazu gehört dass
justizbehörden wenig dafür
sensibilisiert sind dass sie als
gesellschaft nicht darüber sprechen dass
es nicht teil der sexuellen bildung ist
und dass plattform sehr intransparent
arbeiten den plattformen muss ganz klar
sein sexueller gewalt darf keine
plattform geboten werden
tja und politisch scheint das ganze
weiterhin tabu thema zu sein und dabei
ist eins ganz ganz klar wir müssen über
pornographie reden ganz dringend
nicht nur ich habe mich mit dem thema
beschäftigt sondern auch die erste folge
des neuen formats channing das könnt ihr
euch hier oben angucken und hier unten
kommt jetzt zur playlist von zoomin